what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the new insanely
overpowered quirk that was just
introduced in the mha story a
game-changing quirk which belongs to the
strongest woman in the world and the
strongest american hero stars and
stripes i will also discuss her epic
fight against awakened shigeraki
shigaraki's insane internal battle and
yes i will also discuss the moment stars
and stripes pinned shiraki to the ground
with her thighs let's do it you guys
know what to do if you enjoy these
videos leave a quick like comment and
subscribe to the channel for more by the
way we've recently partnered with
aitaikuji an online retailer in japan
that makes anime merch that is normally
exclusive to japan available to fans all
over the world they have a wide
selection of awesome anime merch
straight from japan including an entire
section on mha which has some of the
best mha figurines i've ever seen along
with a bunch of other awesome stuff
check them out the link in the
description and because we're partnered
with them you can now use the coupon
code anime opera 500 for an instant
discount every time you use the coupon
code you are not only getting awesome
merch at a discounted rate you are also
directly supporting this channel so
check them out link in the description
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned the previous chapter ended
with quote unquote shigaraki tomorrow
standing on top of a flying nomu and
confronting stars and stripes along with
her fleet of stealth bombers in the
skies over japan but which shigaraki is
this
is tomorrow himself is it the older
shigaraki also known as all for one or
is it some combination of the two this
question will become increasingly
important as the chapter continues the
title of the chapter is me and myself
for this very reason so i will come back
to it later the new chapter opens up
with the stealth bomber pilots briefing
stars and stripes on the current
situation they confirm that this is
indeed shigaraki or at least shigaraki's
body and they know that he can use
electromagnetic pulse blasts so the
pilots engage their force fields and
disengage autopilot these guys all know
that it's about to go down and in the
most american moment of the entire
chapter the pilot who's flying the plane
that stars and stripes is standing on
asks her for final confirmation about
whether they will engage or retreat and
our girl america chan gives the only
answer that we could have expected her
to give she says there is only one
option left
smash america
yeah oh sorry i i got carried away there
anyway freedom waifu tells the jets to
get information and she promises the
fighter pilots that if they fall in
battle she will return their dead bodies
to their families i mean how considerate
of you america chan seriously though
this is just a brief moment a quick
little exchange between stars and
stripes and the pilots on her team but
this reveals an important difference
between her and most other heroes that
we've met so far this comment isn't just
about stars and stripes being a badass
although she absolutely is she doesn't
really have the mentality of a regular
hero she clearly has the mentality of a
soldier she fights as part of a military
unit she has her own fighter jet
squadron and they operate with strict
military discipline and with a military
code of honor returning the bodies of
fallen comrades to their families is an
important aspect of the military honor
code so with this quick little statement
stars and stripes reveals to us that she
is not just a regular hero like the ones
we've met in japan she is a hero soldier
in that sense she's much more similar to
say captain america than to someone like
spiderman or iron man or even the heroes
we know in mha like endeavour hawks
genus and so on captain america
definitely seems to be the main
inspiration for stars and stripes well
along with all might of course and some
of the panels showing stars and stripes
in this chapter are clearly drawn in the
style of classic american comics which
is likely a deliberate tribute to the
western comics that horikoshi loves and
that influenced his own work horikoshi
has made no secret of his love for many
western comics and the character of
stars and stripes seems to be a direct
homage to them as the americans get
information and prepare for battle we
see that all for one is having a bit of
an internal monologue or is a dialogue
with himself we know that this is all
for one talking because he is using the
word boku instead of the word ore which
is what shigaraki normally uses when
referring to himself all for one says
that he knows for a fact that he is
shigaraki tomorrow and yet at the same
time he also knows for a fact that he is
all for one
it's almost as if he is no longer just
all for one or just shigaraki tomorrow
but some strange unnatural fusion of the
two shigeraki and i will just say
shigeraki because they're both
technically shigaraki that's their
surname and also is just easier that way
but yeah shigaraki then attacks with a
combination of radio waves push and load
up a three quirk combo but amerika chan
and her squadron managed to evade the
attack although just barely and that is
when we get the reveal of stars and
stripes as absolutely insane overpowered
quirk the name of her quirk is new order
and it allows her to give a specific
rule or command to anything she touches
from people and inanimate objects to the
air itself she first uses it to
essentially erase the atmosphere from a
star-shaped space within a 100 meter
radius of her own location since
shigaraki was located within that radius
he suddenly loses his ability to breathe
and he begins to fall to the ground we
also learned that stars and stripes can
impose two of these rules or commands at
the same time and the standard thing
that she does is impose one of the rules
on herself in order to give herself
super strength and agility in this state
she is extremely strong though not as
strong as all might once she gives
herself super strength she uses the
second rule to attack her opponent in
some way now first of all whoa this
quirk is insane and as soon as all for
one sees it in action he immediately
knows that he wants it and honestly who
can blame him this quirk seems to be a
combination of nen from hunter hunter
and trafalgar law's devil fruit from one
piece and if that quirk wasn't enough we
can't forget that freedom rifle also has
a squadron of fighter jets on her team
as soon as shigaraki gets distracted by
having the very atmosphere ripped from
the space that he was located in the
fighter jets shoot a bunch of powerful
lasers right into shigeraki initially
the pilots think that they took him out
but things are never that easy with
shigaraki as awesome as freedom waifu's
quirk appears to be we can't forget that
chicago has a bunch of different quirks
in his possession and he uses reflection
plus refraction in order to shoot the
lasers right back at his attackers
thankfully stars and stripes is able to
change the rule she is applying to
herself to allow her to hold the lasers
before they can damage her and so she is
able to stop shigaraki's counter-attack
in its tracks she then proceeds to leap
at shigaraki with an insane aerial
maneuver that kinda looks like a flying
detroit smash she is able to smash him
in the face and knock him off his nomu
and she then literally pins him to the
ground with her thick thighs and i'll be
real with you guys okay shigaraki
doesn't look like he's complaining all
that much in that moment but moving on
because that atmosphere rule that she
had put in place earlier has already
worn off stars and stripes is now able
to create another rule but before we see
what she is going to do we get a quick
glimpse at amerika chan's backstory back
when she was still a child she and her
family were traveling in a car when they
were attacked by a villain this exact
scene was actually shown in a flashback
to all might's younger days during the
first my hero academia movie two heroes
so yeah a random little girl that was
shown for a very brief period in the two
heroes movie grew up to be the world's
strongest woman and america's strongest
hero how freaking cool is that this
incident happened in california but as
we know from the movie flashback
allmight was studying there at the time
as a foreign exchange student stars and
stripes thought that she was going to
die when the villain attacked them but
she was hoping that someone would at
least save her sister thankfully all
might did his thing and he managed to
save the entire family by absolutely
wrecking the villain after that day all
might became america chan's spiritual
master and she was inspired to become a
great hero just like him she even styles
her hair in a similar way to all might
as a tribute to her master except
instead of two long strands of hair that
all might keeps on top she has eight
long strands now i'm not sure what
exactly she means by spiritual master is
she saying that he actually trained her
in some way or is she saying that he
just trained her in spirit because she
decided to follow in his footsteps does
all might actually have a personal
connection to her or is she just a fan
girl i'm looking forward to finding out
more about their relationship in the
future if there even was a relationship
to speak of as i said earlier stars and
stripes can only impose two rules at one
time she uses one of the rules to make
herself super strong and she had used
the other one for the atmosphere around
shigaraki but once the atmosphere rule
had worn off she touches shigaraki and
calls out his name which allows her to
place a new rule upon him the rule she
creates is that if he moves even an inch
from this point forward shigaraki's
heart will stop yo did she just death
note shigaraki since he obviously can't
remain still during this high flying
battle shigaraki should be done for but
remember when i said that who shigaraki
actually is in this moment is going to
become important later well as all for
one cheerfully explains ever since he
woke up inside chicago's body he knew
that something was off all for one had
been expecting that he would completely
take over shiraki's body within about
two months but tomonashigaraki has
proven to be far more resilient than
expected his hate the hate that has been
growing inside of him ever since he was
just a small child is so great that it
gives him incredible willpower and so
far all for one has not been able to
completely overcome that willpower all
for one believes that he is about 97 or
98 merged with shigaki's body but he's
not quite there yet this means that the
person whom stars and stripes is facing
right now is not actually tomorrow
shigeraki and he is not all for one
either a new being is emerging from
within shigaraki some sort of
combination of shigaraki and all for one
and so because this is not quite the
tomorrow shiraki whose name stars and
stripes had called out his heart does
not stop her quirk did not work
shigaraki is continuing to struggle
against all for one from the inside and
over one is actually encouraging him to
keep struggling and keep hating him all
for one believes that shigaraki's
immense hatred is the key to everything
his hatred will give birth to their
glorious future and of course
shigaraki's hatred is the key to one day
stealing one for all because this hatred
gives shiguraki the kind of immense
willpower required to take one for all
by force and as the incredible quirks of
shigaraki and stars and stripes continue
to clash this chapter comes to an end
with the text on the final page
promising that this epic fight which
basically just started is already going
to be ending in the very next chapter
whoa why so soon and how will it end
more than that what will all of this
mean for the story the fact that offer
one was willing to come here and fight
stars and stripes before shigaraki got
to 100
says a lot about how worried he was
about her joining the fight against him
in japan all for one is risking
everything here and it's because he
knows how dangerous stars and stripes
could be for his plans and now that we
know what her quirk is i'm not at all
surprised that all for one decided to
take this risk but what did you guys
think of freedom waifu's quirk and can
you imagine all the possible rules that
she could create with that quirk it just
seems so overpowered and so versatile
and honestly it is the perfect quirk for
a long and multifaceted final showdown
that the series is building towards
whether it's going to be used by her or
by all for one after he steals it from
her it's gonna be quite a thing to watch
oh by the way random thought but what
about stars and stripes a sister she
mentioned being especially worried about
her sister back when the villain almost
killed her family and we know that
quirks are in part hereditary so could
her sister also be a powerful hero with
an overpowered quirk are we going to one
day meet the sister as well i really
wasn't expecting that the random little
girl from that scene in the movie would
actually become an important character
later so i guess anything is possible if
you guys enjoyed this video and you want
to see more boca here content right here
on the channel just leave a quick like
and comment it only takes a second but
it really helps with the youtube
algorithm and of course if you're new to
the channel or maybe you watch our
channel but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet make this the
video that you subscribe hit that bell
and then select the option that says all
if you don't do that you're still gonna
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
quick reminder to check out itaikuji
link in the description every product
that you order with our coupon code
anime pro 500 directly supports this
channel as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see us
peace cowboys
[Music]
you